- Les yeux de Sylvie Laroche
pétillent encore lorsqu'elle
parle aux résidents de sa RPA.
Mais la propriétaire de 61 ans
est fatiguée. La pandéa a a été
difficile.
SYLVIE LAROCHELLE, propriétaire,
résidence Beauséjour 2003
- Dans la paroiscicici,
il y en a trois qui ont fermé.
Je suis la dernière qui est
ouverte.
- Son prochain défi :
installer des gicleurs parce
qu'il n'y en a aucun ici.
Mais les coûts sont exorbitants.
- On est rendu à 151 767 $.
Ça, c'est la soumission
de juin 2022. Ça fait qu'avec
le COVID, tout a augmenté, on ne
se le cachera pas. Il faudrait
que je me ré-endette quasiment
du prix de la bâtisse pour
mettre des gicleurs.
- Au Québec, il y a encoreununus
complètement équipée de
gicleurs. Et même si
le gouvernement leur donne
2 ans de plus pour se
conformer à la loi,
15 % d'entre elles, environ
75 établissements, risquent de
fermer en raison des coûts qui
ont explosé.
MARC FORTIN, PDG, Regroupement
des RPA du Québec- - - - On demt
du Québec de bonifier
les programmes.
- Parce que les réseaux
d'aqueducs et les puits en
r r r ruraux sont aussi
problématiques.
Ils ne fournissent pas assez
de pression pour les gicleurs.
Il faut donc acheter des pompes
à gros prix.
- J'ai des résidences qui
m'appellent en pleurant qui me
disent : "J'ai un puits, donc ça
va me coûter 150 à 200 000 $
juste pour mettre une pompe."
SONIA BÉLANGER, ministre
responsable des aînés
- On a réservé une enveloppe
de plus de 200 millions $ pour
pouvoir financer l'installation
des gicleurs partout.
- La tragédie de l'Isle-Verte
en 2014, delelelelelle 32 aînés
ont perdu la vie, a marqué
le Québec. Et la ministre
responsable des aînés tient
mordicus aux gicleurs.
- On le voit l'installation
des gicleurs, c'est fondamental.
Et on ne peut pas se passer
de ça aujourd'hui et donc,
on va aller de l'avant et puis
il faut prendre le temps
nécessaire.
- Sauf que pour certains,
le temps commence à p
Et décembre 2024, c'est encore
long. Avec la pénurie
d'employés, le report inquiète.
SYLVIE TREMBLAY, dg, RPCU
- Vous savez que la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre, ce que ça fait,
c'est qu'il y a moins de monde
la nuit, le soir et les
weekends. Et ce qu'on a vu à
l'Isle-Verte est un exemple
concret de ça.
- Six chambres?
- Chaque corridor oui, 12 total.
- Sylvie Larochelle ga
le cap, pour l'instant.
Dans deux ans, ses résidents
devront probablement déménager
ailleurs, vers les grands
centres, loin de leur paroisse.
- Ils ont donné un deadline
plus long, ça fait que moi,
je continue de travailler
jusqu'au deadline. Puis si ça ne
fait pas, bien regarde, ça va
être la fin. On aura pas le
choix, comme bien d'autres.
- Ici Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc,
Radio-Canada, Sai